the teenage boy is
the dumbest
the dumbest
thing on planet Earth
look anything that laughs like this oh
is the dumbest [ __ ] walking
let me tell you
how dumb okay
so my dumb [ __ ] son he had some of
his dumb friends over right oh
and so
this is how dumb they are this is what
they laugh at so they're in their room
and I can hear him laughing oh
I hear my son dad come in here come in
here Dad come in here oh
I go what's going on he goes this is the
funniest thing
and I walk in and so my son and three of
his friends shirtless by the way for
whatever reason they're always all
shirtless
are standing on his bed with a cat laser
you know the thing the cats chase
around doing it around his room and one
of his dumb Friends shirtless
running around like this
just slapping it like he would put it on
his my son would put it on another one
of his friend's chest and his friend
would just come up and go oh
I just laugh like [ __ ] for an hour
chasing a cat laser
I know you're buying your kids Xboxes
but if it's a dude he's too [ __ ] dumb
get him a cat laser if you get him an
empty refrigerator box even at 14 a 14
year old boy would be like there's so
much room in here
they're so [ __ ] oh
what are we doing here well you know you
said I always looked like a dolphin with
my shirt off yeah
that you're going to be the one that
looks like a dolphin
let's go meet your technician how are
you pleasure good to meet you yeah you
nailed it
[Music]